alors apparemment ce filtre
automatiquement de mai un avatar qui tu
ressembles 3 2 1
elle va pas du tout
pas du tout
calvillo proches voudraient talent inné
et aux proches encore fast
r
on n'est même pas dans un truc ya pas de
rouille non les pasdaran et
[Applaudissements]
la guerre on t'a dit
c'est la guerre
bien ou c'est pas la guerre
jamais
chanon xbr
528i capté au bois l'équipe j'en dirais
que là avec une allemande laisse quand
même comprendre ce que je dis elle
comprend rien sg grandes manoeuvres j'ai
grave alors on essaie une banderille
tout à l'heure soit aux toilettes là
j'ai tué les toilettes et une bague riz
[Applaudissements]